welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford School of
Medicine we are now live today with our
annual and lifetime members of The
hubman Lab podcast premium channel and
first off I just want to welcome
everyone thanks so much for being here I
hope you're having a good holidays and
I'll uh wish you a happy new year at
this point and again at the
end I want to kick off our discussion
today by just highlighting some of the
incredible things that you all have
already done the premium channel as most
of you presumably know provides support
for important research and when I say
important research we can Define that as
research that is done on humans with
humans with their consent of course that
we believe stands the highest
probability of leading to New Quality
treatments and improvements in mental
health physical health and performance
so support from the premium channel that
is from you has already allowed us to
make several substantial gifts to
various Laboratories as well as some
other um some other endeavors so I'll
just quickly tell you where those funds
have gone and then I'll tell you
something really truly exciting about
where we're headed in
2024 we'll get to the questions in a
moment but I think this is important to
hear first of all we made a um a
year-long gift and when I say year-long
gift we're talking gifts that I
certainly can say from my perspective as
a researcher who's run a laboratory for
a very long time these are the size
gifts that allow researchers to do
research that they otherwise would not
have been able to do they pay salaries
they pay uh for materials in the
laboratory they pay for the sorts of
things that allow signs to happen that
would not otherwise happen we made a
gift to Dr Aaliyah crumbs laboratory at
Stanford in the department of psychology
uh she studies mindset some of you may
have seen the episode with Ally as she's
called um Dr Crum on the hubman Lab
podcast she's studying mindsets and how
they affect both mental health and
physical health in children and adults
and that work hopefully we'll get a
report back on at some point soon about
how those mindsets can improve
performance in school work Athletics and
other areas of life so the idea here is
that you supported that work through the
premium channel and then that work can
happen and then we can get the
information about what the conclusions
of that work are out into the general
population meaning into the public so
that people can benefit from that
knowledge right away and in many cases
Implement that knowledge we also made a
gift to Dr sain Panda at the Suk
Institute for biological study sain
panda is an expert in circadian biology
and intermittent fasting and the study
he is using those funds for relates to
intermittent fasting as a specific tool
for improving mental health we also made
a gift to Dr Carla shatz in at Stanford
University School of Medicine she's
studying how the immune system and
maternal conditions and in especially
infections or uh of various kinds that
um pregnant women sometimes encounter or
get can affect the developing fetal
brain and that work also relates to stem
cells I know there's a lot of excitement
about stem cells nowadays so I'll give
you an update on that as soon as I can
we also made a substantial gift to Dr
Joanna Stein glass at Columbia
University School of Medicine Dr Stein
glass has not yet been on the podcast
but hopefully she will have time to come
on the podcast at some point soon uh
she's studying and developing novel
treatments for eating disorders uh if
you didn't see the episode on healthy
and disordered eating um sadly uh
anorexia nervosa is the most deadly of
all the psychiatric conditions that is a
great number of patients that have
anorexia nervosa unfortunately go on to
die of uh malnourishment and things
related to malnourishment so it's a
critical critical issue that's not
talked about enough and frankly is not
um well funded enough at the level of
federal funding but um through your
support there's now funding um siphoning
into her laboratory and she's directing
those funds directly at novel treatments
based on neuroscience and habit
formation for eating disorders anorexia
and other Eating Disorders Dr Nolan
Williams also at Stanford who does work
on transcranial magnetic stimulation
which is a tool to non-invasively alter
neural circuits in the brain uh for
purposes of relieving depression and
PTSD and excitingly Dr Williams
laboratory also combines TMS
transcranial magnetic stimulation with
psychedelic treatments um in particular
ibaan but also psilocybin I know there's
a lot of excitement about that and then
last but certainly not least uh we also
funded a chronobiology conference they
were um desperate for funds uh reached
out and we were delighted to provide the
funds for that uh conference those funds
allowed graduate students in postdocs
who come from from Laboratories that
couldn't afford to send those students
in post talks to that conference to
attend that conference and I must say
from a lot of years of experience in the
scientific Community the ability to
attend these high quality meetings is
absolutely critical for those young
scientists to be able to glean important
information and go back to their own
Laboratories and to make novel
contributions also can be the difference
between a new collaboration getting
sparked up or not and uh I should just
mention that the the Research
Laboratories that we fund were at a much
higher level than the conferences but
the conferences I think are also a
really important um way to direct funds
uh for those of you who don't know
chronobiology is how the timing of light
temperature and exercise and eating
affect health so all things that I think
uh people are interested in so uh that's
it for what we covered um and what we
supported in 2023 we're very proud of
the support that we were able to provide
thanks to your help and I am very very
excited to announce that while in 2023
it was scom us the hubman Lab podcast
through your premium uh Channel support
that allows us to make that support and
we had a matching donation dollar Ford
dooll donation from the tiny Foundation
heading into 2024 tiny Foundation is
going to continue to do a dollar dollar
a dollar Ford dooll match excuse me
which is exciting and we've brought on
in addition to that two other donors who
are going to also do dollar for dooll
donations so in other words for every
dollar that the Hub lab premium channel
has or raises in 2024 there will be $3
to match that so this is phenomenal and
what it means is that the scom and
hubman Lab podcast are now doing what's
considered on University campuses as
major philanthropy so very exciting um
and so thank you Oho very much for your
support you are making a difference in
the research and I don't just say that I
know anytime there's fundraisers things
of that sort by the way this is not a
fundraiser This Is Us saying thank you
to you but it's always hard to know
where those funds go and um we make sure
that the whole process is very
streamlined we cut the fat on the on it
in every Dimension so that um the money
can go to discovering new tools for
mental health physical health and
performance so thank you so much okay
first question is
up carollyn a writes I am interested in
studies about the anterior mid singulate
cortex oh yes such an interesting
structure would you please share any
information regarding those thank you
for all you do in the advancement of
science thank you for all you do in the
advancement of science Carolyn and
others listening okay so the enter mid
single cortex for those of you that um
may not have seen the episode on
Willpower and tenacity but even if you
have is a region of the brain that is
involved in leaning into difficult
challenges of all kinds this is an area
of the brain that gets larger when we
Embrace effort that leads to a bit of
internal anxiety but it's something
that's good for us an Adaptive thing and
this is an area of the brain that gets
smaller when we don't engage in
challenging Endeavors now we need to
Define challenging Endeavors very
specifically challenging Endeavors that
stimulate the growth of the anterior mid
singulate cortex are challenging
Endeavors that we would prefer not to do
we may want the end goal right so we may
want the the consequence of the exercise
the consequence of the learning the
consequence of whatever the challenge is
but that the challenge itself feels
uncomfortable and here of course we want
it to be uh uncomfortable but safe
challenges is what is what's going to
grow the inter mid singulate cortex now
another thing about the inter mid
singulate cortex that's important is
that for people that end up being
successful diet or successful um pursuit
of Fitness for people that um complete a
degree or finish an exam or things of
that sort the intering cortex gets
bigger for people that fail to do the
work required to prepare so the
preparation that is uh the Anor Ming lit
cortex actually shows a bit of atrophy
so the Anor Ming lit cortex is an
anatomical and neural reflection of
willpower and tenacity and I think what
people get wrong over and over about the
sorts of findings is that the anterior
mid singit cortex is really responding
to a variety of inputs as a lot of
different inputs and outputs we know
that based on neural circuit tracing but
it absolutely responds best to things
that feel like that they are indeed
difficult that they are a challenge so
if you're like me and you enjoy certain
forms of exercise and it's just pure
Bliss for you the whole way through
that's not going to grow your anti mid
singulate cortex however if you add a
bit of let's say uh higher intensity
work I like doing a long run or hike on
Sundays I don't do Sprints too often at
the end of that uh but if I were to do a
couple Hill Sprints at the end and I
really was like ah this this is rough
this sucks that's actually the sort of
thing that's going to stimulate the
anterior mid singulate cortex the
anterior mid singulate cortex since
Caroline you asked about studies was
actually uh discovered in cases where
people were stimulating this brain area
and the subjects these were people
receiving neurosurgery for other reasons
reported feeling like something was
impending some not impending doom but
there was some
challenge like they were going to head
into a storm something challenging was
coming but the other subjective feeling
that they reported was feeling like they
could lean into it like they're ready
for it they're ready to meet that
challenge so what you're looking for
when you are interested in growing your
inter singulate cortex I'll tell you why
that's a good thing to do is you're
looking for that feeling of Leaning into
challenge that friction if something's
too easy or it's too delightful that's
not going to contribute to your ID
singulate cortex function and growth I
might contribute to other things indeed
it will um and life isn't all about
leaning into challenge but why would you
want to stimulate your anterior mid
singulate cortex in this way and by the
way those challenges can come from
physical Endeavors it can come from
language learning it come from a hard
conversation that you're um you've been
putting off that's hard for you to have
Lord knows we all all have those aspects
of Our Lives the things that we're
putting off or that are hard for us or
that feel difficult again keep these
Endeavors safe never want to do anything
that would damage your mental health or
physical health but leaning into
challenge in that way does seem to
activate and grow the enter mid
singulate cortex now the advantages of
that is that there are studies excuse me
showing that the so-called superagers um
the superagers I don't like that name so
much it should it's a bit of a misnomer
they call them super agers but they
really should be called super non- aers
because these are people who seem to
maintain healthy cognitive function much
longer than most individuals their
memory their IQ is remains stable into
their much much later Decades of their
life or even improves over time and then
the correlation and again this is
correlation but these are these people's
interior mid singulate cortex does not
atrophy and in general what the studies
point to and there still needs to be
more data collected on this is that
these people are regularly engaging in
things that are hard for them and
challenging and they've embraced that
challenge so lots to say about interior
mid singulate cortex uh but I think uh
that grabs the top contour and um I'm a
big fan of trying to do something
difficult at least one thing uh ideally
every week
um and perhaps even every day a little
bit it doesn't take much uh maybe even
just five minutes it's that friction
that feeling oh I don't want to do this
I can't do this and then continuing to
practice or continuing to lean into that
challenge safely of course uh that is
going to grow that anid signate cortex
and I just think that's amazing right we
hear so much about brain atrophy and
memory loss and etc etc as we get older
a lot of data now about how to preserve
health healthy physical function here
we're really talking about how to
maintain healthy cognitive function and
the interent mid singulate cortex seems
to be barometer of how well we are doing
that Mark s asks would love to hear more
about an evening routine and not just
morning especially when it comes to
light oh I love this question I love
this question because I've made a lot of
changes in the last year related to this
because um you know there's this guy on
the internet that talks about the
importance of getting morning sunlight
I'm just kidding
um there are several of us but um and
gals but um I I suppose I've been quite
vocal about the importance of getting
morning sunlight as soon as possible
after waking and of course of course of
course unless you have powers I'm not
aware of if you wake up before the sun
comes out people always ask what do I do
you wait till the sun comes out if it's
overcast you get outside a bit longer if
you want to wake up before the sun comes
out turn on bright artificial lights now
these days I've actually been playing
around a little bit with some bright
artificial lights um before I because I
tend to wake up before the sun is out
it's the winter months but in any case
I've talked a lot about the morning
routine in the early part of the day and
a bit about the afternoon uh part of the
day evening routine okay well I'll tell
you ideal and then I'll tell you what I
do um I'm always shooting for ideal but
I'm human I think there's this idea on
the internet um that I've seen that you
know my whole life is is protocols
protocol protocol protocol and indeed
sometimes it looks like that and indeed
sometimes it doesn't I'm human things
happen um we all encounter different
challenges so to answer your question
directly Mark I think it's I know it's
very important that if possible that you
get a little splash of sunlight in your
eyes in the afternoon and evening why
why is that important and what we're
really talking about here is not
necessarily seeing a sunset at the beach
although that would be great if you
could do that but getting some sunlight
in your eyes before the sun goes down
maybe for 5 10 minutes it's not as
important as the morning sunlight but it
does have a great benefit and the
benefit is it adjusts the sensitivity of
the neurons in your retina and in your
brain such that it protects you against
brighter artificial lights later in the
evening now it doesn't protect you
completely but what it does is if
normally and this is true bright light
viewed for 15 seconds or more between
the hours of 10: p.m and 400 a.m. I'm
talking about somebody on a standard
schedule not shift worker Bright Lights
viewed for 15 seconds or more between
the hours of 10: p.m. and 4:00 a.m. can
dramatically quash melatonin levels
melatonin being the hormone that's
involved in feeling sleepy and falling
asleep it does other things as well of
course it's secreted from the
pineal we know based on a really nice
study publish in science reports that if
you view that afternoon late afternoon
evening sunlight you don't have to be
too strict about the time get you know
pop your sunglasses off as long as you
can do that safely get some sunlight in
your eyes or if you can't look directly
at the Sun and by the way never stare
directly at the Sun at least getting
some daylight in your eyes before the
sun goes down that can offset that
melatonin reduction by about 50 % which
is pretty impressive now you would still
do well to dim the lights in the evening
and and one thing that I've been playing
with recently is uh using red lights so
um a lot of people when they hear red
lights they think oh you're talking
about you know Red Light Panel which
that has its uses those tend to be very
bright red lights or um you know
portable red light I actually use a
small portable red light looks like a
piece of thick piece of toast um I use
that for other reasons this is not what
we're talking about with evening routine
with evening routine it can be
beneficial and very very
costeffective to get some red bulbs and
put them in say the bedroom where you
read before you go to sleep or in a
particular room in your house you tend
to spend time in in the evening makes
for a nice mellow feel but it also does
several other things first of all it if
they're the correct red bulbs and I'll
mention the ones that I've been using in
a moment they uh eliminate all the blue
wavelengths that tend to be stimulating
for the what we call the noradrenergic
system so adrenaline noradrenaline
cortisol Etc indeed there's a study
shows that when shift workers who have
to be up at night use red lights of the
type that I'm describing when they work
under red light they have less of a
cortisol increase than were they to work
under standard fluorescent lights or
even standard LED lights so number one
thing would be dim the lights in the
evening and at night as much as you
safely can to perform whatever functions
you need don't fall you know don't burn
yourself at the stove you know if you
have to Rite and do work as I often do
you need light uh but to the extent that
you can shift to Red Lights uh that can
be helpful and many people many people
and myself included find that you get
sleepier when you do that so I might
just do this for the last hour of the
evening even if I'm up till 10 or 11: or
if I do it earlier then I tend to get
really sleepy but those red lights um
you know I put have a little lamp above
my bed I'll do that if I'm going to read
in bed I make it much easier to fall
asleep probably because of the reduced
cortisol associated with eliminating the
blue wavelengths and they tend to be
fairly dim and um now there's one brand
of red light that um you actually can
that actually will work on a dimmer so
this is important um I suppose you could
use a red party lights or Christmas
lights those could be very affordable um
some people do that put kind of festive
uh feel in the room other people like
myself um will um use a red light that's
dimmable I want to mention that what I'm
about to say I don't have any Financial
relationship to this company in terms of
the bulbs um red light panels are
different I use the ju um I use ju type
but for red lights that uh for the
purpose I'm talking about that would go
into a standard lamp and that you Dim
where has a very different purpose right
the red light panels have a very
different purpose than than red bulbs
that you would put into a standard light
fixture uh the dimmable ones um are
called they you can find them as red
light you just put Bon um it's a the uh
technical name uh of the company is um
sorry forgive me for Googling this now
yeah it's a bond charge b n separate
word charge um and those are dimmable
and they have the prop ER wavelength so
that's what I use um they're not super
cheap but they're not expensive either
in in comparison to most uh red light
therapies or something so we're not
talking about red light therapy we're
talking about reducing the overall
amount of blue light in your environment
Etc now for many people who don't want
to purchase something new and again I
have no Financial relationship to bond
charge so I don't glean any thing I buy
them with my own money and I just have
one or two of them and I dim the lights
even those red lights I dim while I'm
reading at night and then fall
asleep if you don't want to use red
lights for whatever reason then you
would be wise to just dim the lights
that you have and we possible to have
those lights be set fairly low in your
room environment now why would that be
okay well first of all the cells that
activate the alertness system uh in the
brain through via the retina your eye um
tend to look up into your environment
and that makes sense because they're
essentially there to view sunlight and
the the presence or absence of sunlight
but in addition to that think about it
logically if I take a flashlight and I
shine a beam on the ground or at a tree
in the yard it looks very bright but
you're not getting all those photons in
your eyes right you're seeing it at a
distance as opposed to shining the light
in your eyes it's very very bright okay
so when you have lights that are
overhead and going into your eyes it's
very different than the light being on
the floor or on a Surface this gets back
to something that I often get asked how
could it be that viewing sunlight
through a window takes 50 times longer
to activate your circadian system than
it does when you step outside well let's
think about that when you step outside
there's sunlight everywhere if you face
the sun there's even more coming at you
but when you're inside unless there's a
beam of light coming through that window
and the window is very clear or open for
that matter you're not really getting
the light in your eyes in the same way
that if you're outside with the sunlight
in your eyes right it's the same thing
as like looking at a beam of light from
a flashlight against a wall versus the
beam of light going at your eyes okay so
we talked about um dimming the lights
setting them low in the room the I it's
not red light therapy but changing over
to Red Lights Bon charge is probably
just one of many out there I've seen it
done pretty nicely with just somebody um
people grab red party lights go on
whatever your favorite search engine
sales site red lights and you could do
that that's going to be better than any
blue lights and then if you're going to
be on your screens here's what I suggest
there's a short cut function in your
phone where you can triple click to
switch your phone over to eliminate all
the blues this is very different than
just using the nighttime function very
different and um I think we should
probably put out a video on how to do
this but what you do is you go into the
accessibility function on your phone you
go into to color filters and then you
drag down the the blues but that's not
how your phone is going to be set all
day CU then you don't see anything
that's in blue but you can introduce a
triple click function I'll put out a
clip soon on how to do that and so when
I go to sleep at night or in the evening
what I'll do is I'll triple click and
I'll switch my phone over to uh to Red
only and uh that's completely zero cost
by the way it doesn't cost anything and
then in the morning when I wake up it
click cck click and turn on although I
try and get the sunlight in my eyes
before I look at my phone okay Tom M
asks
light therapy recommendations for those
that live in northern regions with
limited morning light or too cold to get
outside for Morning Light Dark when
waking do red light therapy great
question I'm going to take a sip of this
bone broth
because at the rate I'm speaking if I
try and keep this up for an hour and a
half I I might um get a little horse red
light therapy is different than what I
just described red light therapy is the
use of red light panels can be smaller
panels like the small ju that I use
which is a unit it's about the size of a
piece I guess they call it Texas tote
toast right they Texas a thick piece of
toast I don't know maybe someone knows
why it's called Texas toast um I guess
it's big um it's about the size of a
piece of toast provides very bright red
light and in between those red lights on
there there tends to be near infrared
light so far red so um you know to a
biologist red doesn't mean as much as
the wavelength of light so wavelengths
in like the 650 to 800 nanometers is
what we're talking about whereas blue
light is down in the you know four and
500s and really like 535 to you know low
sixes um you know like the rainbow right
um red orange green blue
um there are also larger red light
panels and nowadays I also see a lot of
um advertisements for red light panels
you can actually lie down in red light
beds here's the story red lights will
often be marketed as the most powerful
the most intensity the most locks most
important is the proper wavelengths or
are the proper wavelengths so that's why
I use the ju because ju has the proper
wavelengths of red and far
red the distance to view a red light of
that sort generally is about 18 in
sometimes a little closer now sometimes
people would put red light on different
parts of their body I covered a bit of
this in the light and health episode but
red light because it's longer wavelength
light can permeate through tissues to
fairly substantial depth how deep
depends on the tissue if you put it up
against your skull is it going to get
down into your brain no it's not going
to get through your skull
maybe a little bit if it's a very
high-powered red light if you're holding
a red light of that power at home
something's wrong I don't that's a
medical that's a medical device however
ju are medical grade red light and near
infrared lights and they um are quite
powerful they're the right wavelengths
actually that's why I prefer ju because
they are um they are medical grade
um they can be directed at your eyes in
the morning for the purpose of there's a
a study out of two studies is actually
out of Glen Jeff laboratory at the
University of College London showing
that viewing red lights at a distance of
about 18 in or so in the morning for
people who are over 40 but not for
people younger by the way that can
offset some of the age related
reductions in mitochondrial function and
vision loss so I look at a red light in
this ju my ju Texas toast light or I
have a ju panel um at a distance of
about I confess I stand about 12 to to
18 inches away
and I do not force myself to look at
that light I don't hold my eyelids open
I allow myself to Blink so I'm
comfortable truth told you could
probably close your eyelids and some of
that red light is going to get through
your eyelids not a ton but some so no
problem blinking you never ever ever
want to look at any light sunlight or
otherwise red light any light so bright
that it's painful to look at if you have
to Blink it's too bright step back if
you have to Blink every once in a while
that's okay but if you have to Blink in
order to to close your eyes in order to
protect your eyes then you're standing
too close in the morning you can do red
light therapy on skin you can do it on
eyes will it wake your system up will it
provide the kind of uh cortisol increase
which by the way you want early in the
day and adrenaline and dopamine increase
that sunlight can provide the answer is
no sunlight is unique in that way
however if you live in an area of the
world that's too dark or um you wake up
long before you get sunlight in your
eyes what can you do well you can flip
on artificial lights you would do that
the opposite of how I recommend in the
evening you'd want to flip on overhead
lights as bright as possible if you um
have the disposable income and you want
to invest in a 10,000 Lux Light Panel or
900 Lux Light Panel again I have no
Financial relationship to these
companies but um there's a light panel
900 Lux drawing tablet that I've set on
my desk for a number of years recently I
confess I've started um uh experimenting
with some of the 10,000 Lux light panels
that sit on your Des desk excuse me
those are very very bright and I do use
that now if I wake up really early and
I'm going to do some work I'll turn that
thing on and it sure wakes you up now is
it as good as sunlight no it doesn't
have the right color features and
alternation between yellow and blue that
morning sunlight has and that evening
sunlight has and without doing a whole
tutorial when the sun is low in the sky
So-Cal low solar angle sunlight you'll
notice if you take a picture with your
phone provid it's not a cloudy day
you'll see that there's a lot of blue
yellow contrast and that's the optimal
stimulus that said if it's overcast out
you should still get outside because
some of those W lengths are coming
through even though you can't perceive
the blue and the yellow so these you
could get a 10,000 Lux light but if you
can't afford that or you don't want to
oh and by the way those you you set on
your desk you turn on for 5 10 minutes
while you're making coffee and things of
that sort they actually recommend that
you don't keep them on too much some
people actually can feel a little too
euphoric or maybe even get a little
headache because it's a lot of blue
light so that's one thing the other
thing you can do is that if you can't uh
uh access light of any kind just dark
dark dark that's where the cold shower
really can help because you get that
adrenaline bump um early in the day
which is good so early in the day you
know provided you're not going into
states of anxiety as a consequence of it
getting adrenaline dopamine cortisol
increases is great and then as the day
goes on in the evening and night time
certainly you want to taper the levels
of those neurochemicals off now of
course there's always going to be some
cortisol there's always going to be some
epinephrine there'll always be dopamine
your system if you go out dancing you go
to a party at night should you worry
about the lights no okay I am not
despite what you might presume or hear
or read I am not
uh the sort of person who wear
sunglasses at a party although the other
day I was at a party and someone was
wearing sunglass I think it was for
other reasons the um the that that gives
the impression there was something bad
going on I think they were just like
looking cool by the way um and they did
look cool but I don't do that and if I
drive at night I don't wear I don't wear
um sunglasses I do and I have been
exploring the use of blue light filter
glasses in the evening and those red
lights in my house but for I think for
most people if you get out every once in
a while you go out to a late night you
go out dancing you have a party with
friends you know you get home dim the
lights maybe use those red lights get to
sleep early in the day Bright Lights
ideally from sunlight bright bright
bright bright bright how bright as
bright as possible and as many as you uh
is
reasonable except to the extent that it
could damage your eyes so don't be
staring at any Bright Lights excessively
okay I think that that pretty much
summarizes it and then of course early
day it's really about sunlight or light
of other kinds cold water if that's your
thing if that's not your thing that's
fine
there was no tablet that uh descended
down to us telling us that we had to get
into cold water each day it's an option
it's all an
option Dennis from Munich I love Munich
haven't been there in a while but I used
to
go in MOX plunk Munich for a number of
um times per year and I missed the food
I missed the Schnitzel as we approach a
new year what health and fitness metrics
do you recommend checking oh good one
and could you share your annual medical
Fitness check routine okay
um what I'm about to say I'm sure will
um generally jive with what Dr Peter AA
who I'm sure you all know and who I um
respect tremendously also grateful to
call him a close friend uh basically
asserts is important for Fitness
um I think if you're going to do a
fitness test you know Peter's got it in
mind and I generally agree you know you
deadlift your body weight 10 times in
the same set hang from a bar for a
minute or more okay in the same set um
these sorts of things I tend to be far
less PE class about it frankly uh my
goal is always the same I'm 48 years old
I've been doing the same training
program ever since I was
16 more or less I mean I've had you know
you know Peaks and valleys in terms of
my consistency based on other
obligations and of course when I'm sick
I don't train sick people stay out of
gyms please nothing makes me more
frustrated than people showing up to get
their work out and getting everybody
sick here's the
deal I try to be capable that is ready
for various things what the ability to
go on a long hike what's a long hike 5
to 10 miles with some hills the ability
to Sprint for the airplane without
blowing a
gasket the ability or that means hurting
oneself or having a heart attack the
ability to carry some heavy furniture
with assistance safely or God forbid to
take a trip and not damage myself and of
course to have some level of agility and
uh coordination so how do how does one
do that so what Health Fitness metrics
do I recommend checking well I'm going
to do this next week because it's the
end of the year but pretty much every
week it's the following three
cardiovascular training sessions one is
long meaning an hour to 90 minutes
that's going to be slow for me so this
could be a weighted hike so waight
vested hike or you could just put some
weight in a backpack just be a hike if
it's really steep or a long slow jog
once a week for me it's jogging or
hiking for other people cycling or
swimming sometime in the middle of week
I'm doing a 35 minute run so maybe five
minutes of warmup and then a faster 35
minute run you could also do it on a
rower you could also do it on a bike but
you're really pushing up around I don't
know maybe I I don't tend to measure
heart rate but where it's I could not
hold a conversation I'm working I'm
working working I'm not sprinting but
I'm working and then another time during
the week a shorter workout of about 12
minutes it's going to be 3 minutes of
warm-up some calisthenics a little bit
of cycling on an assault bike or
something of that sort assault bikes are
the ones where you have the handles with
the fan or it could be a rower or it
could be any sprinting a hill and then
doing sometimes one minute on one minute
off for 12 minutes sometimes doing 20
seconds on 10 seconds off for eight
rounds and it's real work it's getting
the heart rate all the way up VO2 max
the combination of those three three
types of cardiovascular training
sessions are that I'm ready to Sprint
for the airplane I'm ready to take a
long hike anytime I'm I can go out for a
two mile run and really enjoy that if I
if I need to it's a Readiness thing and
I think it covers all bases am I ever
going to be a marathoner or a champion
sprinter with that or a Myer no but
that's not my goal and it never has been
I ran a cross country race in high
school and we tell out story another
time it was a lot of funun until I hit
the second mile
the other thing I do three times a week
is I work out with resistance training I
train my legs one day so that's calves
hamstrings quads I train my torso so
that's I do some pushing for my
shoulders and upper chest and some dips
that kind of thing some pull-ups some
rowing this sort of thing and I train my
neck because I'm a big believer in that
for the upper spine but um don't don't
go at it heavy it's just really to
maintain you know uh posture and to make
sure that upper upper spine is supported
something that most people
neglect and then one day a week I
do smaller body parts like I'll do my
Cal train my calves again biceps triceps
I'll make sure that if they're any small
body parts that happen to miss during
the middle of the week because of
scheduling like rear delts or something
I'll do that maybe a little bit more
neck work or some ab work okay those are
spread out about a day apart I don't get
too obsessed with the spacing between
those workouts but they're not all
stacked against one another so it might
be in my case it's it's long run on
Sunday this is just how I do it Monday
tends to be off uh excuse me long run on
Sunday or hike Monday is legs excuse me
Monday is always legs Tuesday off
Wednesday I generally would do that
shorter run or the Torso work I
flip-flop them depending on how my legs
are feeling and the next day I do
whatever I need to do either the Torso
resistance training or the or the 35
minute run and then Friday is that
faster clip cardio Saturday tends to be
the smaller body parts biceps triceps
Etc I must say these days of the week
always have the ability ability to slide
when we or the other so for instance if
I'm traveling and I don't get back on
Sunday until late I'll if I was not able
to do that training while I was on the
road then I will do it on Monday and
then I'll just slide things around so
that I finish off the week with
everything done and I can get back on
schedule but the way I've arranged it
every body part gets hit twice once
directly once indirectly and the
cardiovascular training is is covers all
bases why train this way well it ensures
strength it ensures whatever aesthetic
changes you want you can emphasize
working harder in more sets perhaps for
the things that you you know want to
bring up certain body parts that are
that are weaker you can um certainly
recover because you're only training
legs once a week but guess what you're
you're doing them on Monday and you're
sprinting on Friday so they're getting
hit indirectly on Friday even if it's on
the bike though that fast hard pedaling
with resistance is going to make sure
that your legs aren't going to atrophy
you can still get butt you can still
train them again on Monday again so this
schedule is designed in a very specific
way none of the workouts except the
longer workout on Sunday that jog or
Runner is longer than an hour ever it's
10 minutes of warmup and 5050 minutes of
work in the gym sometimes 60 sometimes
I'll truncate it to 45 or 40 if I'm
really I have a bunch of things going on
so this sort of schedule sounds like a
lot but it's not it's actually a very
small investment it's about an hour a
day and not even on Tuesday which is a
rest day so what are the metrics that I
recommend checking well I'm a big
believer that if you're sleeping well
and your appetite is consistent and
you're feeling generally good that's an
important metric it's a very subjective
metric but that's important are you
sleeping well or are you waking up sore
and you're not able to recover are you
feeling like no matter how much sleep
you get you can't feel rested these
kinds of things now there could be other
factors involved but that's the you know
sort of a basic one the other one is how
much energy and pep are you bringing to
your workouts that's important and it
relate to caffeine and fueling and all
those sorts of things which we're not
talking about right now it's far too
much to talk about here but we did Cover
in the foundational Fitness protocol by
the way all of this is put into a PDF
that's available online at hberman
lab.com zeroc cost simply go to the
newsletter T tab under the menu and you
can scroll down um below that find the
foundational Fitness protocol gets into
sets and Reps and loads and all that
kind of stuff completely zero
cost I do take my morning resting pulse
rate I know what my pulse rate ought to
be if it's elevated substantially and
I'm not particularly stressed about
something then I might pay attention to
that and back off a little bit on the
intensity on things if I have a throat
Tickler I'm not feeling very well I'm
really careful about working out
sometimes I'll do it sometimes I won't
I'll make sure that isn't just some sort
of like dust or allergen in the
environment but if I'm feeling under the
weather I'll take I'll just skip I just
skipped that workout and some people go
oh you you skip because you're you know
I'll be honest I'm 48 been training very
consistently I am fortunately knock on
wood a little bit suspicious knock on
wood I have avoided major injuries I've
been able to train consistently and I've
also don't tend to succumb to colds and
flu I think about once every 18 to 24
months I've had colder flu of some sort
for for many years that's been the the
kind of cadence but not more frequent
than that I think in part because I
don't tend to push really hard when I'm
sick I tend to be the guy who goes all
right I'm feeling kind of under the
weather should I train maybe not okay
I'm going to take a hot shower and get
in bed at 6 PM read and go to sleep if I
wake up at 3:00 a.m. because I went to
bed too early just chill in bed and read
maybe fall back asleep maybe not I think
taking care of oneself in that way is
very beneficial and then people say well
you haven't had kids well I've had kids
in the house and I also know
what it is to get sick because of
roommates and all this stuff and working
with people and working in a medical
center you're always exposed to things
so um I hear you loud and clear we can't
avoid exposure to um infectious vectors
as they're called um delightful in the
form of kids but uh the reality is I try
and back off when I'm not feeling well I
push when I'm feeling good I'm not one
to do two a day workouts and I'm very
careful about not exceeding my my
program I'm very careful about that that
I don't go crazy I don't do two Pilates
classes then go to the gym and I'm also
not the guy who's complaining about his
back or always being sick and I do not
have you know like phenomenal genetics
for with respect to Fitness you I'm
small jointed or relatively have
mediumsized joints you know I'm not
particularly strong nor do I have
particularly strong endurance you know I
think I'm kind of in the middle so in
terms of medical Fitness check I do
blood work every six months I find that
to be that has identified a few things
that for me needed taken care of and I
pay a lot of attention to overall
feelings of well-being and I chart them
frankly I on my calendar it's my are my
workouts I put the level I put like L1
to 10 typically my workouts are in the
six to8 out of 10 intensity I'm not
measuring this by any kind of um device
and if I get sick I tend to look back
and say what was going on before I got
sick you know um if I'm getting
substantially weaker or I'm feeling uh
fatigued I I I take stock of what's
going on so I think um some people get
the impression that I'm like hyper
analytic about all things and um you
know I would say Atia is much more into
measuring things and I love that about
him I'm more of the mindset like if I if
I'm feeling good and I feel I'm like I
can move my body well not too many aches
and pains occas I get a little something
of a little D disc bulge or something
but and and then I take care of it but
in general it's about being able to feel
good seated feel good moving be able to
have that Readiness Readiness Readiness
for me that's the foundation of of
health so um other uh things you get a
regular eye exam I do have an
appointment in Opthalmology Department
do that air puff test for glaucoma there
are treatments for glaucoma but you need
to know if you have it a lot of people
don't know if they have it it is the
second leading cause of blindness
worldwide second only a cataract it's
very easy test you can get from
optometrist or opthalmologist get that
eye test your vision is so precious I
mean vision is so precious so I I can't
overstate that enough it's uh generally
pretty inexpensive as well especially
from the optomet rist and the drops work
Pablo F asks what do you do with waking
up in the middle of the night and can't
go back to sleep oh such a good question
I have three different tools that I use
first of all long exhale breathing just
to try and calm myself I also try and
relax my face if I do this right now
it's going to be funny but relaxing the
face tends to relax the jaw and then
I'll do a progressive body
relaxation I do use the Revy re v r i
app and they have a specific hypnosis
for falling back asleep hypnosis is
self-directed hypnosis David Spiegel
who's been a guest on the podcast his
voice is terrific for hypnosis even just
thinking about his voice makes me want
to go under typically with Revy you
practice the falling asleep falling back
asleep hypnosis it's only eight minutes
long you practice that in the daytime
and then you can use in the middle of
the night if you need to that does
require that you have your phone present
and by the way if you're going to do
that hypnosis you can select whether or
not you're going to do the one where you
have to interact and speak or not I like
the one where you don't interact also if
you sleep next to someone it won't wake
them up revery is great for this purpose
and and you might think hypnosis that's
wacky or that's um you know Magic Carpet
stuff but it's not this is uh you know
hypnosis by the way is one of the few um
approved Medical Treatments for various
psychological psychiatric conditions
we're not talking about stage hypnosis
people clucking like chickens we're
talking about you learning to
self-direct relaxation which is a skill
that you can enhance in hypnosis such as
with Revy I think Revy now is a a free
trial and it's available on Android and
Apple and it's a nominal cost when you
compare to things like supplements or
sleeping pills it's a few dollars each
month maybe $78 something like that
someone will tell me but if you think
about the cost relative to you know some
other purchasable it's relatively low
the other thing and this is something is
completely zero cost and I can't
encourage it enough is that you get into
a regular practice of nonsleep deep rest
nsdr or Yoga Nidra and that you do that
during the daytime there's a 10-minute
nsdr that I did which is available on
YouTube you just put nsdr huberman it's
available completely zero cost
it will teach you how to self-direct
your own
relaxation and you can also use in the
middle of the night if you wake up many
people fall asleep during ndrs that's
fine or yoga nras many of which are
available on the internet free okay
completely free Yoga Nidra is a little
bit different than nsdr it is a category
of non-sleep deep rest that includes
intentions and things of that sort
self-directed relaxation but relaxing is
a skill now there are a few things that
you can do to avoid waking up in the
middle of the night one is try and limit
the total amount of fluid that you drink
in the last couple hours before sleep
don't go to bed with a super Full Belly
um some people find that if they take
theanine which is something that is in
the Sleep stack that I recommend and by
the way I don't necessarily believe that
everyone needs to take supplements in
order to sleep I think you should get
the behavioral stuff the light the
exercise not drinking caffeine too late
in the day avoiding alcohol ideally
completely but maybe late in the day
especially etc etc and if you can't get
your sleep right that way then perhaps
you start to rely on or enhance your
sleep capabilities with supplements but
they're certainly not a
requirement the sleep supplement
theanine which is in the so-call hubun
lab sleep stack which includes magnesium
and8 and appenine uh and theanine
theanine for some people can really
create vivid dreams and then they wake
up from those dreams they have a hard
time falling asleep in that case I would
just reduce the dosage of or eliminate
the theanine some people like to use
anoco 900 milligram anoco because they
prefer that and it that works better or
uh for them than the Sleep stack or some
people even take it in addition to the
Sleep stack um as long as dosages are
followed there's no reason to think that
any of the stuff isn't safe but of
course check with your doctor before
adding or removing anything from your
supplement protocol or any protocol for
that matter I say that to protect you
not to protect me the other thing that
you can do if you wake up in the middle
of the night is to not look at the time
now that's a little bit difficult if
you're going to look at your phone but
you know this is something that Folks at
the Stanford Sleep Clinic taught me that
people who look at the time when they
wake up in the middle of the night
generally have a harder time falling
back asleep so that to the extent that
you can refrain from doing that and
certainly don't get on your phone and
start scrolling social media um try nsdr
try the revery app try yoganidra try
some long exhale breathing all those
protocols by the way include long exhale
breathing and if you're taking melatonin
before sleep oftentimes you'll fall
asleep very readily and then wake up so
if you're taking melatonin you might
want to reconsider that melatonin does
have its place for treatment of jet lag
and things of that sort in the acute
situations and not taking it too often
but in general dosages are too high
people take too much of it and too often
in my opinion but that's just my opinion
and then I would say if you wake up in
the middle of the night and you simply
cannot fall back asleep just remember
that you can survive one night with
minimal or no sleep unfortunately we've
all had to deal with that if it starts
becoming a chronic condition then you
may want to talk to a sleep specialist
but we've done multiple episodes of the
hubman loud podcast the master your
sleep perfect your sleep we have a sleep
newsletter that you should definitely
download it's zero cost again hubin
lab.com newsletter go to menu newsletter
and you can find that for those of you
that subscribed to the premium channel
I'm guessing that you're a aware of
these um various uh tools but one thing
we know from the Sleep Lab at Stanford
is that when people are excited about
their next day sometimes they wake up
and that their sleep actually can be
less than normal and they can function
well the next day in fact there have
been two studies at least that I'm aware
of two studies there may be
more showing that when people are given
a quote unquote poor sleep score their
cognitive Performance and Physical
performance has diminished even if they
slept really long and really well so
they've lied to them in these studies
conversely if people haven't slept that
much and they rece receive a great sleep
score they perform really well so these
sleep scores while I like them I look at
my eight sleep sleep score or whoop
sleep score
some people use aura rings and things of
that sort you don't want them to drive
your perception of how available you are
for hard work and cognitive function
it's why I tend to rely largely on
subjective measures unless you were
talking about things like apob or
cholesterol levels you know subjectively
uh guessing what your apob level is is
not a good approach right or resting
heart rate they're real metrics but you
want to be careful about relying too
heavily on um Biometrics gleaned from
devices even if they're accurate don't
put too much weight into them take the
average see how you're doing lately if
your sleep score is dropping each day by
15 20 points well then pay attention to
that or your heart rate's going up or
it's going down you know averages
averages averages you know and so be a
scientist of yourself coach Ruby writes
what's the best protocol for strain
training without hypertrophy for women
great question when I've lifted heavy
weights I tend to bulk up fast okay want
to embrace more resistance train without
the bulk great question so here's the
interesting thing about weight training
that's kind of
cool you will never get larger than the
so-called pump that you achieve in a
single workout what do I mean by that
well a lot of people and women in
particular are concerned about getting
quote unquote too big too bulky and
indeed some women some men react very
quickly to weight training they have
high fiber density and for whatever
reason um could be hor hormones but it
probably also has to do with um
different types of proteins that are
expressed in the muscles and even the
connective
tissues some people just grow quote
unquote faster from weight training but
I will tell you this no one's ever
looked at a weight or picked up a weight
done a set and then hypertrophied so
much that it was permanent right the the
so-called pump the blood flow that you
get into a muscle gives you a little
window into what that muscle might look
like if you feed it and rest it properly
so it can recover in hypertrophy so does
that mean that you should avoid the
so-called pump the blood flow into the
muscle
no what do we know from gosh I guess it'
be 40 Years of uh physiological data and
probably hundreds of years
of um just outside the laboratory data
that very heavy weights in the range of
one to three repetitions generally make
people stronger but there isn't much
hypertrophy when you get from three to
five repetitions you're still in the
mostly strength some hypertrophy range
when you get out towards six repetitions
out to even 30 repetitions provided the
sets are going to failure you can't
perform another repetition in good form
well then you're stimulating hypertrophy
now there are exceptions to this there
are exceptions if you do for instance a
one repetition set with a weight but
that weight allows you to do that set
over the course of 75 seconds that's a
lot of time under tension and you can
get hypertrophy in addition to that
weight training that involves an
accentuation of the negative the
Ecentric the lowering portion of each
repetition also will stimulate
hypertrophy but also strength gains so
if you're somebody who wants to strength
train and strength training is oh so
important not just for muscles but for
neural function in the brain and
elsewhere in the body then you really
don't want to put on any size whatsoever
I would encourage you to explore some of
the protocols that Dr Andy Galpin and I
discussed on the exercise series that we
did with Dr Galpin that would be largely
training of after a warm-up of course in
the 1 to three repetition range and even
some training that's done strictly for
power moving the weight quickly at loads
that are substantially lighter although
for some people just because their
genetic makeup they are going to react
with hypertrophy that kind of training
so I would say if you want a weight
train which is a great idea and you
don't want to put on size but you want
to get stronger training that one to
three repetition range now that does not
necessarily mean one repetition maximums
you know eeking out the absolute last
what single rep that you can with the
most amount of weight maybe you back off
on your single repetition maximum you're
still just doing one repetition but of
course if you want that repetition to be
of any value in in inducing strength
then you should be getting close to your
one repetition Max but um keep in mind
also that if you're doing three
repetitions heavy weights but you're
only resting you know 30 to you know 120
Minutes between sets well then you can
get a kind of compounding
effect where you can induce hypertrophy
so if you react that well um and by the
way many people do or there are some
excuse me many most people do not some
people do to low repetitions then you
may have to increase the weight and
lower the repetitions even further long
rest just make sure that if you're doing
that kind of training if you're
concerned with overall health and not
just powerlifting or being really really
strong that you're also doing some
cardiovascular training which includes
you know walking plenty and the sorts of
cardio that we talked about earlier
Steve says what are your thoughts on
these full body scan MRIs that are
becoming quite popular do you think
these are beneficial or are they
unnecessary well I got one um and I paid
for it I didn't get it comped or
anything and I must say I learned a lot
um fortunately I learned I don't have
any tumors at least not of the size that
could be detected by that MRI I also
learned that I have a disc bulge that
explains a lot of times in my life life
where I do a certain movement there's
one or two movements that I do in the
gym we running and a certain stride
where that thing goes and confirm that
um so I've managed to uh I'm very
grateful that uh I only had one white
spot on my brain the white spots are
considered naturally occurring typically
um lesions of the of neurons um everyone
has these you're allowed one per decade
of life before they start to consider it
a potential problem I think I have that
right um um there's not a whole lot you
can do for those by the way except don't
get any more head hits if you're doing a
contact sport or construction or
something where you can you know but
some people still have to continue to
work and if that's their work they have
to work so yeah I think it was it was
informative for me um I watched a
Netflix movie in there was pretty cool
um the movie wasn't very good but it was
cool that you can watch Netflix in there
it's pretty easy to do they're not cheap
they're a couple thousand doll minimum
um it was reassuring to me to not see
any tumors on my liver tumors on my
kidney knock on wood you know I mean um
and to see that I didn't have a lot of
intrav visceral fat or anything like
that I mean I I doubt I'm the healthiest
specimen that rolled has ever rolled
through there but it was it was
reassuring to me that I wasn't dealing
with a bunch of white spots on the brain
I wasn't dealing with that sort of thing
and you know is it necessary no no it's
not also some people don't want to know
what's going on under the hood is it
unnecessary is what you asked that's a
tricky one I mean it really depends on
finances and how curious you are I will
say this my good friend and former guest
on the hubin Lab podcast Dr Eddie
changen who's a medical doctor and chair
of neurosurgery at University of
California San Francisco when I told
asked him about it and I told him I got
one he said oh yeah we get people coming
in all the time patients all the time
who've gotten these whole body scans for
recreational purposes or because they
were curious and they will identify
issues that need to be resolved with
neurosurgery now that splits my answer
in two because that's kind of scary
right that could there be could you be
walking around with tumors on the brain
and not even know it yeah absolutely for
a lot of tumors are benign a lot of
tumors don't impinge on areas of the
brain or body that create problems and
never create problems and others create
problems and um do you want to know do
you want to get that tumor excised there
are a lot of non-invasive ways to deal
with tumors nowadays um I guess it's a
question of whether or not you want to
know and when I say want to know I mean
obviously everyone would love to know
that they have a clean bill of health
under the hood but do you are you
prepared for what might happen
psychologically and medically and what
you would have to do in order to remove
an issue that maybe not an issue right
um it's possible that you have a you
know you have a growth or a mass that's
benign but you know then you have the
anxiety of the period in between So It's
Tricky um some tissues like prostate
tissues or um different tissues in the
uh female reproductive tract can be
enlarge but not be problematic but then
people might want to make changes that
to ensure that the enlargement doesn't
continue I'm a big believer in data I
like data so while I'm not big on
tracking my sleep every night I do track
it at night but I don't necessarily put
too much weight on any one individual
night's sleep score um and by the way if
you get a really lousy lousy sleep score
chances are you know youve slept poorly
if you guys great sleep score chances
are you know you slept well um it's the
stuff in between that that kind of gets
people interested um I don't know I I
think for me I I was happy to get the
bill of health I did and had I
uh discovered something that needed
dealing with I guess I'd be grateful
that I went in for it um so that's my
answer but again they're expensive I
hope the cost comes down I hope
insurance will cover these
eventually Orca La Vista what a great
name Orca La
Vista awesome um asks would you as a dog
lover considering doing an episode on
dog wellness and communication
yes yes absolutely I love dogs I love
dogs so much it's ridiculous
I just do I just I I like being around
them I like thinking about them I like
hanging out with them and they're family
members right Costello is a family
member and I um I'm eagerly anticipating
getting another dog probably when we get
back from tour in Australia from
Australia um I'm not going to bring back
an Australian Shepherd they have like
way too much energy for me I like the
Mellow dogs I like economy of effort in
a dog which is why a bulldog or a
Mastiff is probably a good one for me
yes yes and yes
pet health is key relationships with
pets are key don't get a dog that you
can't take great care of and Bulldogs
are a ton of work and they're very
expensive plan on spending at least I'm
not kidding $20,000 a year in medical
bills on a dog to keep a bulldog to keep
them
healthy adopt if you can a lot of dogs
out there need need be adopted heid M
says I need advice I'm 32 I'm working
out for 2 three years but my left arm is
weaker than my right how do I balance
muscle strength between sides different
weights or strategy great question well
I guess you're assuming it's a lot
weaker I mean I am a big believer in
doing unilateral movements I can't
remember last time I did a barbell curl
or or a or a you know the thing they
call the Easy Bar tricep extension I
almost always do unilateral stuff
dumbbell curls I think the real key if
you want a weaker arm or limb to get
stronger is that mind muscle connection
you know it means presumably unless
there's some sort of under underlying
neurologic thing and I don't want to
scare you it's always possible it seems
unlikely based on the way you worri the
question is that you want to make sure
you're gripping the handle the weight
really tightly by the way that will
increase your strength and performance
on a set to grip tightly there's neural
reasons for
that and that you're really working hard
to contract the muscle and also use
weights that you can control remember
when you lift weights for the sake of
getting stronger it's not about lifting
weights you're actually using the weight
as a tool to stimulate strength and
hypertrophy increases so it's a tool and
you don't walk around with the weight
number on your body you walk around with
the muscle development that you achieved
and the strength that you
achieved with a particular weight and no
one cares what that weight is so if
you're you know if you can't carry two
bags of groceries up the stairs um it
doesn't matter if you were able to you
know carry 400 lb dumbbells through the
gym right I mean that's why I think the
Readiness thing is key I think we think
so much about the gym as the as the end
point but the gym is a place for
training for the rest of life in my
opinion it also happens to be fun for me
but um if your left arm is weaker I
would emphasize well you could perhaps
do more sets certainly I would do you
could do all your left arm sets first
then your right arm sets if it's really
substantially different you may actually
want to stop training the right side as
intensely for a period of time and get
that left arm up there uh things like
that but I like unilateral work I don't
do a lot of unilateral work for my legs
let me think I do leg curls no that's
both legs same time I definitely try and
pull with both legs same time leg
extension same time uh hack squat same
time glute ham same time okay yeah um
just keep training it but don't
overtrain it if it's really weak because
you're giving it 25 sets make sure
you're allowing time for it to recover
and by the way I don't know um uh how I
I don't recall because the question's
gone now how old your but you give your
body time give your body time I started
training when I was 16 give your body
time
it takes time to train correctly and it
takes time to develop a strong mind
muscle connection and you don't don't
rush don't run out there and start using
you know uh don't get cavaliere with
Pharmaceuticals or anything else just
take your time enjoy your training the
best advice I ever got about training um
with somebody very accomplished and he
said and I really internalized I like
learn to and you may delete the learn to
learn to enjoy training really hard or
just love training hard I love training
hard I love it I love it I love it so
just learn that like lean into that
process and enjoy it and if you and if
there's certain parts that are
challenging remember you're increasing
the size of that medial interior mid
singulate cortex last question really I
was I was hoping we just keep going
maybe I'll do like a 24-hour marathon of
this and then we also do it as a as a
study in sleep deprivation does anyone
want to vote for that I've done that
before I used to work 36 hour stretches
when I was in graduate school no joke we
would do these physiology experiments my
producer here is sitting here going like
don't do it but it's righta by the end
of those experiments we'd be wearing tin
foil on our heads and we were doing
these experiments but we built a lot of
resilience we used to survive on In and
Out Burgers and I was like don't eat the
bun because the carbs will make you
sleepy and then we' we'd argue about it
and we' you know we'd start to
hallucinate somewhere around the 30 hour
mark and my friend Kenzo he's now a
professor back at uh University of
Maryland so he can he can vouch for that
story but gosh that was fun I I don't
miss it I was in my 20s uh 30s yeah no
20s late 20s um
but if people think it be maybe we do a
fundraiser like to ra raise extra money
for research and I'll do 24 hours of
just answering questions around the
clock and just see how you know see at
what point I just completely and then I
can also teach you guys how to do a
proper all nighter because there are
tools and the one of the main tools is
don't trust your thinking between the
hours of 2:30 a.m. and 4:00 a.m. so
maybe during that time we just all
meditate together all right last
question until we do the 24-hour hun lab
AMA Marathon do you have plans to
produce more content or protocol
specifically for children's development
and health yes we're going to do a
children's or Child Development series
that also extends into adolescence and
young adulthood I'm also going to be
doing episodes on that some amazing
guests for that I'm going to do some
solos as well are there any current
resources you recommend for this topic
yeah I like Alan Shore's book it's a
little little detailed little technical
um s c h o r e Allen Shore I think it's
how you spell it let me check let me
check at
UCLA um little Tech alen Shore
yeah a l l an separate word s c h o r e
a psychologist in research it really
talks about um regulation of the he
talks about right brain left brain in a
way that actually is accurate there are
very few people talk about right brain
left brain accurately he does and talks
about attachment and emotional
regulation and um it's mainly focused on
early childhood development there's some
beautiful um you know there's some
beautiful stuff out there that's that's
been comes from the the psychology
literature and Neuroscience literature
on this but I'm also going to get my
friend um Dr Linda wilbri on the podcast
she's a professor up at Berkeley studies
adolescent development there's just so
many great folks out there that we want
to bring on to the podcast and we will
organize that into um some protocols and
things of that sort lot of work to do
for us to get it all you know succinct I
realize sometimes podcasts are long you
know sometimes people ask I often get
asked you know what are the plans for
20124 what are you going to do keep
improving the content we actually have
some shorter form content coming out I
don't want to um give away what that is
you know some 30 minute episodes that um
capture the essence of of the most
important protocols in science um and
yeah the goal for 2024 and forward is
just keep improving the content uh and
trying to make it as succinct and
digestible for you as possible but also
as thorough you know I if I go real
short for them then important details
will get lost but Child Development is
extremely important and remember we're
always in development development
doesn't stop when we hit hit 25
development is is an arc from birth
until death which hopefully will be a
long time uh from now for all of you and
um there's just a ton to explore there a
lot of science psychology protocol so
we're going to get into all of it so I
was told that's the last question I
confess I'm a little bit sad about that
I could just keep going um but maybe
we'll do this again at some point and I
think we should do that 24-hour Marathon
as a fundraiser I don't know what you
think but I I'll I would do it anyway
that's the that's the truth I'd be here
anyway um I want to thank everyone for
tuning in thanks ever so much for your
support of the labs I mentioned
earlier if you know somebody who you
think might be interested in the the
premium channel let them know that they
can watch the early parts of those
premium channel episodes on YouTube and
listen to them on Apple and Spotify
without having to to log on for you know
not having to pay not everyone has the
resources for those of you that devoted
resources to the podcast the premium
channel just know that it helps support
the regular podcast which of course is
available costree to everybody it really
subsidizes that and it's also
subsidizing this uh this research that's
taking place in these Laboratories and
we're going to expand the research we
got that $3 to1 match uh for 20124 so I
really enjoyed today that's the truth I
love your questions I could do this all
day every day uh we have we're going to
record an episode today and tomorrow um
and I'm basically just going to keep
talking till they tell me it's time to
stop so when someone in the corner goes
like like this then I'll stop if you
ever been to one of our Live Events like
they're supposed to end 9:30 there you
go they're telling me to stop it's
time's up thank you everybody I hope you
had a great holiday I hope everyone has
a very Happy New Year's if you're like
me and you're going to be sleep by 10:30
on New Year's um enjoy the good night's
sleep and enjoy New Year's Day I'm a big
New Year's Day guy get out on New Year's
Day and enjoy something and just
remember whether or not you're doing
behavioral protocols or you're super
into the supplements of the red lights
the most important thing is those
pillars of you know sleep nutrition
exercise Stress Management sunlight I
guess we're getting up to six and social
connection so it's it's a lot to try and
do all that all the time don't pressure
yourself meanwhile thank you for
everything that you do for us and last
but certainly not least thank you for
your interest in
[Music]
science